MAKE THEM PAY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
AND TONIGHT THERE'S FINALLY AN
ARREST IN THAT BRUTAL ATTACK ON
A CONSERVATIVE VOLUNTEER ON THE
CAMPUS OF UC-BERKELEY.
FEBRUARY 19TH HAYDEN WILLIAMS
WENT TO RECRUIT CONSERVATIVE
STUDENTS AND THIS WAS THE
RESPONSE.
[BLEEP]
>> WELL, IT TOOK POLICE TEN DAYS
TO ARREST THIS MAN, WHO'S
CLEARLY IDENTIFIABLE TO ANYONE
WHO KNOWS HIM.
28-YEAR-OLD ZACHARY GREENBERG
FACES ASSAULT AND BATTERY
CHARGES.
HERE NOW IS THAT VICTIM AND HIS
ATTORNEY.
HAYDEN, HOW ARE YOU DOING?
>> I'VE BEEN BETTER BUT I'M
RECOVERING AND ALL RIGHT.
>> YOU CAN LOOK AT ME.
THAT'S ALL RIGHT.
YOU DON'T DO A LOT OF TV.
WE APPRECIATE YOU JOINING US.
ANYONE WHO'S BEEN PUNCHED IN THE
FACE, IT HURTS.
WHY DID IT TAKE SO LONG TO FIND
THIS GUY?
>> WELL, I THINK DUE PROCESS WAS
BEING FOLLOWED, WHICH I
APPRECIATE THAT AS A
CONSTITUTIONAL CONSERVATIVE
MYSELF.
I'M GRATEFUL THAT THE POLICE DID
THEIR JOB AND FOUND THIS GUY,
BUT I REMAIN DISAPPOINTED WITH
UC-BERKELEY AND THE FACT THAT
THEY ALLOWED SUCH A CULTURE OF
INTOLERANCE AND VIOLENCE TOWARDS
CONSERVATIVE VIEWPOINTS TO GROW
AND THRIVE.
>> IT WAS AN ATTEMPT TO SAY,
DON'T TRY THIS AGAIN.
YOU'VE REPRESENTED A LOT OF
PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN TREATED
TERRIBLY JUST FOR THEIR
VIEWPOINTS.
>> THE NEXT STEP IS NOW THAT
HE'S BEEN ARRESTED, THE
INVESTIGATION WILL GET TURNED
OVER TO THE PROSECUTORS OFFICE.
THE BAIL IS SAID FOR ONE COUNT
OF FELONY ASSAULT WITH GREAT
BODILY HARM.
YOU CAN SEE HE HAS A BRUISE ON
HIS FACE TWO WEEKS AFTER THE
FACT.
IN PREVIOUS INCIDENTS ON THE
CAMPUS, THEY'VE BEEN PLED OUT
APPREHEN
AND THE FELONY CHARGES ARE
DISMISSED AND NO CHARGE IS
SERVED.
THAT'S MY CONCERN RIGHT NOW.
>> ARE YOU GOING TO FILE A CIVIL
SUIT?
>> WE DON'T WANT TO GET IN THE
WAY OF THE CRIMINAL PROCESS.
I THINK THAT'S REALLY NUMBER
ONE.
NUMBER TWO, HE APPEARS TO BE
SOMEBODY WHO HAS A HISTORY AT
UC-BERKELEY, SOMEBODY WHO HAS
WORKED FOR THE CAMPUS FOR A
PERIOD OF MONTHS AND ALSO
AUDITED CLASSES THERE.
AND AS HAYDEN SAID, IT IS COMMON
FOR THESE ANTIFA TYPE THUGS TO
FLOAT AROUND, MENACE PEOPLE,
THROW PUNCHES.
MY CLIENTS AT UC-BERKELEY HAVE
EXPERIENCED THIS MANY TIMES.
>> IS THIS GOING TO STOP YOU
FROM BEING INVOLVED?
>> THIS IS ONLY EMBOLDENING ME.
>> WELL, MAYBE TAKE A LITTLE
TAEKWONDO.
YOU GOT HIT IN THE FACE.
>> THIS GUY IS TWICE THE SIZE OF
HAYDEN
>> A LITTLE ROUNDHOUSE KICK TO
THE SIDE OF THE HEAD.
BUT IT'S MEANT TO INTIMIDATE.
THIS IS MEANT TO TELL ANY
CONSERVATIVE ACROSS THE COUNTRY,
DON'T TRY THIS AGAIN BECAUSE
WHAT HAPPENED TO THIS YOUNG MAN
IS GOING TO HAPPEN TO YOU.
IMAGINE IF IT'S A YOUNG WOMAN